evga's GTX 1070 SC is priced at $440
making it sadly one of the most
affordable GTX 1070s presently available
but prices should come down a bit
because the low end is still 380 MSRP we
haven't seen that hit Market just yet
though because as many of you have
pointed out in comments the 1080 and
1070 are both very limited availability
right now and that means that they're
very expensive in the case of the 108
800 plus doar if you can find it at all
still though these cards from what we've
been told by EVGA should become
available on mass probably in the next
month or so July is their expected time
range for actual availability of these
cards in a greater quantity than they
are now the card we're reviewing today
is the GTX 1070 SC it is stock clocked
100 megaherz faster than the reference
design which is this one and that puts
evga's card at 7 1984 MHz core and it's
also using the ACX 3.0 cooler which is
the biggest change here as is often the
case with aib partner cards because the
reference design cooler although uh
Nvidia claims premium materials and what
have you is actually pretty poor at
cooling the GPU itself as we've shown so
we're reviewing this thing today we're
going to be talking about its value
overall FPS metrics noise thermals
overclocking things like that as always
Link in the description below for the
article which has more charts than we'll
be showing here and we'll hopefully give
you some additional Insight EVGA
superclocked cards are their most
affordable tier of pre-overclocked GPU
and this one sits about 100 MHz faster
than reference the GTX 1070 SC takes two
expansion slots and is a more normal 4.4
in height the same as the expansion slot
height generally and makes it smaller
than the GTX 1070 gaming X from MSI that
we also tested ACX 3.0 uses a dual fan
design each with two ball bearings rated
for lawn service life against ACX 2.0
the ACX 3.0 design uses a marginally
thicker fan blade to reduce turbulence
of the blades thereby reducing vibration
and rattle within the fan which should
help control some of the noise overall
and drop the worrying sound that we've
heard in some previous models we'll test
noise levels in a moment though like the
twin frozer and stricks cards evga's ACX
3.0 spins down to zero RPM when under
minimal load in terms of processing or
thermals and that means it produces
effectively zero noise until the fans
spin back up ACX 3.0 also uses round
heat pipes as evj has done in the past
but adds a conductive filler between the
Heat pipe and the heat sink this helps
improve the service area for heat
dissipation and spreading and is
becoming more common as MSI with their
twin frozer 6 card used square heat
pipes when it connects with the cold
plate so that's becoming a bit of a
trend the heat sink on evga's SC card is
mounted to to a base plate that contacts
the vram and vrm components like mosfets
with thermal pads in between the base
plate and those components and is part
of what makes up the ACX 3.0 cooler and
is also what you'll find on the 1080
cards and other cards in the future as
far as visuals ACX 3.0 gets a slight
facelift versus the previous version of
ACX which would be 2.0 and it now has
led backlights also new the GTX 1070 SC
uses white LED backlights but the FTW
cards will have RGB backlighting
controllable through EVGA software all
right so that's the walkthrough now
we're going to do thermal benchmarking
first just to bring everyone up to speed
we represent these numbers in delta T
over ambient and that means we subtract
ambient from the measured value there's
a few good reasons for that I've
discussed them before but very briefly
the ambient temperature of a house
environment even a thermal chamber
fluctuates from second to Second and
those can be several degrees in some
cases so we sub track that to normalize
the results and uh also when you're
looking at the results for your own
environment you'll want to add back in
your own ambient temperature because
it's not going to be the same as here so
that's why we do that these are delta T
which means you'll want to for this
Environ add in about 20 to 22 celsius to
get kind of our absolute value but just
add in your own ambient temperature for
a better idea the GTX 1070 reference
card has a maximum temperature of 53.86
C Under full load measured with a 1683
MHz stock clock that's about 25%
different from the MSI GTX 1070 with
twin frozer 6 cooling landing at
41.77 celsi when in OC mode at 1797 MHz
evga's GTX 1070 SC with ACX 3.0 cooler
is
13.84% different from the Fe card and is
at 46.8 n Celsius which puts MSI and the
lead between the two but it's a much
larger card so you have to keep that
into account so here's a look at our
noise data as you can see we test a few
different ways first of all the noise
print at the bottom is the footprint of
noise in the room before our test we've
got 100% test where the fans are
configured to 100% speed that is both
fans in these cases we've got 50% test
where the fans both are running at 50%
speed we have idle which in the case of
the EVGA 1070s and the MSI 1070 gaming X
means they're running at zero RPM so
that is the noise of the system that'd
be the PSU and the cooler the CPU Cooler
in this case and then we've got the auto
test which shows what you should expect
under normal gaming circumstances
without a custom vanan curve all right
now we're going to move on to FPS
benchmarking we only have a few games in
this video but article in the
description below if you want to see the
full charts for all the games we tested
GTA 5 shows almost identical performance
between the EVGA and MSI GTX 1070 cards
with the Fe card only marginally behind
at 1080p with very high and ultra
settings the EVGA 1070 SE runs at 1217
FPS average and 87.3 FPS 1% low which is
identical to what the MSI card is
outputting with its only 13 MHz speed
difference the 0.1% lows are the only
location where we see a difference and
the MSI card is leading by a bit about 2
FPS or so at 4K similar results are
netted MSI leading by 1 FPS average EVGA
leading the 1070 Fe by about 1.5 PS so
nothing exciting here but somewhat
expected since we're really just
comparing the same architecture GPU
everything with different clock rates
Black Ops 3 at 1080p it shows the GTX
1070 from MSI at 175 FPS average and the
1070 SC from EVGA at 171 FPS average
with the MSI card sustaining generally
higher 1% and 0.1% low values it's
stable clock rate is some of this by the
way that doesn't really mean that
there's a noticeable difference at this
this obscenely High frame rate but there
is a measurable difference the founders
Edition card sits at 166 FPS which is a
difference of about 2.97% moving to
1440p we see the EVGA GTX 1070 SC and
MSI 1070 gaming X are effectively tied
with the MSI version of the card leading
by 0.7 FPS again completely
imperceptible to the user the cards are
for all intents and purposes identical
in performance at this setting with this
game and against the ref 1070 there is a
slight gain of 4.2% moving to the 1070
SC from EVGA but that's about all we get
at 4K the EVGA GTX 1070 performs at 55
FPS average and sustains highly timed 1%
and 0.1% lows at 43 and 40.7 FPS
respectively these are superior to the
fury X which looks fine and its averages
but fails massively in the 0.1% low
Department as a result of its limited
vram capacity that creates noticeable
stuttering and msi's GTX 1070 gaming X
doesn't have this issue it runs at 57
FPS average and that's a gain of 3.57%
over the EVGA card the reference card is
at 53.3 FPS average and they're all
pretty close at 4K mostly because it's
such an abusive setting anyway Shadow of
Mordor puts the EVGA GTX 1070 at
121.71a 1070 and about 1 FPS ahead of
the reference 1070 1440p we see a gap
marginally widening between the
aftermarket cards and that puts them at
86 FPS for EVGA and 89 FPS for MSI or a
3.43% difference the founders Edition
card again at 1440p is at 77 FPS which
is actually noticeably slower than the
aib partner versions in fact it's
actually 14.46% slower than MSI and 11%
slower than EVGA and this result
coincides with our original 1070 Fe
overclocking results that showed that
Mordor is sensitive to the clock rate
increases Mordor at 4K shows the EVGA
1070 SC at 49 FPS with MSI at 51.3 FPS
and the Fe card at 40.7 FPS or
noticeably slower than both it's
actually 18.5% lead for EVGA over the Fe
card so that's a pretty noticeable jump
almost 20% and is a reason why you would
want the a partner card other than The
Thermals the noise and the price if you
need more reasons in terms of dx2 12
we'll just show ashes of Singularity
here which serves as one of the new API
Benchmark games on our test platform at
1080 High we see similar tiering as
before MSI 1070 marginally ahead of the
EVGA 1070 SC and that's slightly ahead
of the reference card between the MSI
1070 and the reference 1070 there's a
more noteworthy gap of
8.79% the MSI 1070 and EVGA 1070 are
separated by only 3.8% between the two
of them 4K High post similar results MSI
card runs at 49.84 FPS average in dx12
with EVGA running at 47.75 FPS average
the reference card finally sits at
46.276720
plus one phase power design for the vrm
and it's also got the same power header
here so it's just 1 18 pin as opposed to
something like this MSI 1070 which has
an 8 pin and a six pin so considerably
more power there about 75 Watts extra
total power budget whether that's tapped
into of course depends on a few other
things but that's the theoretical power
budget on that one now as we've said
before we use real world applications to
validate our overclock so as supposed to
using something like just furmark where
you generate one very specific type of
load and place it on the
GPU and don't necessarily see failures
until getting into games we do only
games or fire strike or something real
world and that means that our overclock
numbers are numbers that you should
reasonably be able to achieve on your
own device with General allowances for
the Silicon lottery so let's get into
the stepping for the GTX 1070 SC with
evga's GTX 1070 SC we were observing a
maximum core clock rate of 1847 MHz with
fluctuations ranging between the 1786
MHz range and that Peak Point pushing V
core further and of course doing some o
gives us room but not a ton of room and
we ended up with a 2025 MHz core clock
that's with a 50 MHz offset from the
EVGA pre OC base which is different from
the founders Edition which has a
obviously plus zero mehz procc we also
had a 4608 MHz memory clock on evga's SC
device and the power Target maxes out at
112% on this card with vcore maxing out
at
1.75 volts clearly this is an Nidia V
bios limiter for safety let's switch
over to our Founders Edition card charts
so you can see how this one steps up on
the Fe card and this is from our Fe
review when it first launched we were
able to hit the very same 4608 MHz
memory clock so that makes sense since
they're basically the same Hardware but
we had a slightly lower 1987 MHz core
clock not that much lower though some of
that difference can be chocked up to the
Silicon Lottery and some of it can be
attributed to just Superior cooling on
the EVGA card which is helping us
stabilize the clock rate as you pit It
Against Time and look at the charts that
way MSI on the other hand they go a bit
hard so here's the look at their
stepping the MSI GTX 1070 we've got
that's the gaming X is pushing 2 75.5
MHz core and 4799 MHz memory that's an
extra 50 MHz or so on the core that
we're getting with an additional 200 MHz
memory overclock MSI is using a custom
PCB it's taller and it has a 10 plus one
phase power design and an extra six pin
power header for another 75 wats of
power budget both of these do contribute
to the additional clock rate gain over
the EVGA 1070 SC card despite using a
custom V bios though from what MSI told
us anyway the card is still stuck at a
1.75 volt VC cor and that is something
we validated the bit that MSI told us is
that they have a custom V bios and that
it should allow for some extra over
voltage but we're not really seeing that
here so we are seeing the same 1.75 volt
Max for each of these devices and the
1070 Founders Edition card as for
performance results with overclocking
here's a look at the FPS metrics now
generally we're seeing gaps of a few
percentage points 1.8 is to 3.5% on
average with only a few clock sensitive
test showing anything more than that
that's pretty expected for this type of
OC though as the cards are already
relatively close to their limit and
you'll only see actual gains in OC clock
sensitive applications and there are a
few games that do that and in some
production applications so is this EVGA
card worth it well the 1070 SC falls
mostly where the 1070 reference card
Falls in terms of frame rate metrics
your main differences are outside of FPS
which makes sense cuz there's a lot more
to these things than FPS thermals are
critical often underd discussed and that
is one of the places where the SC card
does outperform the 1070 Fe handily and
to that end with the EVGA 1070 SE again
we were hitting
46.8 n Cel load delta T versus 53.86 C
for the reference design that's an
improvement and it's at a 100 MHz
additional clock rate boost over what
you get stock on the Fe card MSI does
outperform EVGA particularly with
overclocking but the outperformance is
really not that much in gaming terms Now
The Thermals MSI does pretty darn well
with their thermals and most of that can
be chocked up to this right here you'll
see the 1070 SC is pretty much
completely aisc that's cuz this card is
much bigger it's got bigger fans nearing
100 mm and a larger block of aluminum
and copper to help cool the thing so
that's where you are seeing most of that
performance difference with The Thermals
noise the noise levels of all these
things well of of these two things I
should say are pretty similar as you've
seen in our noise charts and that really
brings us down to two things which is
price and availability the thing is as
we've said now the 1080 and 1070 today
as of this video are pretty hard to get
a hold of especially at their actual
reasonable prices a lot of retailers are
gouging right now as they're doing for
the rx40 pre-orders and that's not
something you want to fall into the Trap
of because it's not worth it so the
range for these cards is supposed to be
I lay this down because it keeps falling
uh the price range is supposed to be 380
to
450 we're not seeing that right now this
card is priced at 440 you can find this
particular gaming X from MSI at
460 and then you can find the gaming non
X which has a lower clock rate for and a
more similar vrm phase design to this
card you can find that one for 440 as
well uh either way
$440 uh this this card is good this card
is also good but uh I I wouldn't spend
440 today I would certainly not by the
founders Edition card when you've got
these two options on the table literally
in this instance but they're just it
it's still a little too expensive for my
taste I think as these fall closer to
the 400 to 420 Mark that would be where
I would be more of a buyer for one of
these cards and that's not to say the
extra $20 is unfair or gouging but it it
just it feels a little higher than it
should be strictly because Nvidia did
advertise that price floor as $380 so I
would hang out a little bit let the
stock in the inventory hit the shelves
let it replenish itself as these
retailers are able to get stock and meet
the supply and demand without crazy
fluctuations that they're seeing right
now you will see these prices stabilize
a bit there'll be rebates things like
that free games whatever uh and that
will all help with the value proposition
but uh as a video card the 1070 SC is
good the ACX 3.0 cooler is substantially
improved over this if you don't want a
blower fan this is a good option it's
got the LEDs if you like those I don't
normally talk about Aesthetics but you
can figure that out on your own
overclocking is okay it's not anything
to get excited about this has better
overclocking it might be more fun you're
not going to see a performance
difference that's really noteworthy but
you will see extra clock rate increases
that you won't get on this card by
nature of the improved vrm phasing and
more power and things like that so that
should pretty much sum it up if you're
trying to spend less this is the way to
go hopefully it falls from 440 but
otherwise I'd hang out for probably 3 to
six weeks in that range you'll see more
of these Pascal chips hitting shelves
and after then the 480 will be launched
anyway so there'll be some pressure to
bring these prices down to what they
should be based on the initial unveil so
that's all I got for you this time
overall that's it no no real strong
positive or negative either way just
depends on what you're looking for in
the price patreon link the postol video
if you want to help us out Link in the
description below for more information
and thanks for watching I'll see you all
next
[Music]
time
oh